what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it does indeed look like Marvel
Studios is getting ready for a big
Fantastic Four announcement at San Diego
Comic-Con this year or at least they are
trying to get ready for a big
announcement if everything gets done on
time meaning if they actually have the
full cast of The Fantastic Four
completely finalized in which we do have
an update on that today and we're not
talking about just the main members of
the actual Fantastic Four team but who
the villains could possibly be as well
is Marvel Studios planning on just
announcing the main team for the
Fantastic Four or are they gonna bring
out the main cast which would include
the villains and some side characters as
well are they going to present this to
us at San Diego Comic-Con we'll break
down everything that we know in this
video so we've been speculating for a
long time now that Marvel Studios is
going to do something pretty big at sdcc
this year and if you've kept up with our
recent videos you know that their could
potentially be so much coming at sdcc
including the full reveal of Marvel's
phase six but Marvel Studios doesn't
typically just reveal projects during
their San Diego Comic-Con haulage panel
they typically talk about some upcoming
projects ones that are coming out sooner
rather than later and also take the time
to announce the castings for new
projects coming out and usually how this
happens is the cast members will
actually come on stage and this is what
we're expecting for several different
projects because a lot of the projects
that are coming out relatively soon
Marvel Studios has already done this for
they did a lot of it last year they had
a lot of the cast members for each of
the projects come out and they've been
doing it recently as well at other Comic
Cons in fact really the entire Daredevil
cast and Echo cast has been going around
and been talking on stage and this
includes Charlie Cox and Vincent
D'Onofrio and they have talked a lot
about what to expect for Daredevil
Vincent D'Onofrio who of course plays
Kingpin in the Netflix series Daredevil
and now in the MCU has actually talked
about Spider-Man as well and he says
that he is going to eventually meet
Spider-Man so already some big reveals
dropping at other Comic Cons but San
Diego Comic-Con is the event of the year
for Marvel Studios Hall h and since
we've already gotten a lot of the cast
members for a lot of the projects that
are coming up especially the phase five
projects what's left is the phase six
projects and right now we only have four
of those projects revealed so that's
what we're expecting to see the cast
members of two projects because we
already know that Avengers the King
Dynasty is going to feature The Avengers
that we already know are a part of the
MCU and then other multiversal Heroes
who probably aren't actually going to be
announced at sdcc probably ever they're
probably just going to be presented in
the Kang Dynasty or other films that
explore the Multiverse I doubt they're
going to reveal any of the major cameos
that are going to be coming during
Secret Wars at an sdcc event so that
means that as of right now there are
only two Marvel phase six projects that
have been revealed of which Marvel
Studios needs to reveal sort of the full
cast for and that is Deadpool 3 which we
already know Hugh Jackman is returning
as Wolverine so I can't wait to see that
on stage I hope everybody is available
so Hugh Jackman and Ryan Reynolds can
take the stage together at San Diego
Comic-Con and talk a little bit about
what to expect from Deadpool 3 and then
of course the next one is the Fantastic
Four in which right now we basically
know nothing about officially yes there
have been rumors about some things in
the Fantastic Four like Sue storm and
Reed Richards are already going to be
married they're already going to have
kids and the Fantastic Four is already
going to be well established already but
really nothing has been stated directly
from Marvel Studios with the exception
of the director but besides that nothing
official has come directly from Marvel
Studios but we have heard from some
pretty reliable sources and some big
media Outlets of who the cast is going
to be and the cast right now is
apparently rushing to be finalized for
the this big San Diego Comic-Con
announcement so apparently Marvel
Studios does want to indeed announce who
the cast members of the Fantastic Four
are at sdc's Hall age panel but the cast
is not 100 finalized this report is
coming from Grace Randolph and she
posted on Twitter yesterday movement
still happening with Fantastic Four
casting this one will be down to the
wire to close the deals for Comic-Con
MCU panel and with whom I hear Sue storm
is still not locked however today she
would go on to state that I'm hearing
all roles back in play again others are
being considered again meaning nobody is
truly locked down yet for the Fantastic
Four casting and she also tweeted about
why this is she stated here's the issue
with the Fantastic Four cast Marvel
decided to go for big stars for some
reason yet now they all want big paydays
and the movie has four leads so 80
million for the cast alone that's not
nuts what happened to the MCU being in
the star making business I much prefer
that now this isn't actually counting
the villain of the movie either right
now the rumored villain for the movie is
Galactus and right now the rumored actor
to play Galactus is Antonio Banderas so
if Grace Randolph is stating that it's
going to be around 80 million for the
main fantastic forecast alone that's
about 20 million per actor plus another
20 for Antonio Banderas because he is a
really big name so a hundred million for
the main cast that is pretty big and
we've recently heard that Emma Stone was
offered the role of Sue storm The
Invisible Woman but she turned it down
because she wanted more money in Marvel
Studios wouldn't give it to her so that
is kind of a problem when it comes down
to Casting these really big name actors
even though it's the MCU and a lot of
actors become really well known once
they're in the MCU these actors who are
already well known still want to get
paid and they want to get paid what they
think they're worth which makes sense
but also at the same time Marvel Studios
does have a budget for the project and
you don't want to cut Corners by
spending too much money in other places
however the actors who are going to play
the main Fantastic Four members are
extremely important and Marvel Studios
has to get that right and so far the
fans have been mixed about who the
rumored cast is so far which is Adam
Driver mostly known for playing kylo Ren
in the Star Wars universe as read
Richard slash Mr Fantastic Margot Robbie
who of course most people know as Harley
Quinn as Sue storm slash The Invisible
Woman Paul muscal who isn't such a big
name but who is still a very talented
actor as Johnny Storm AKA The Human
Torch and David Diggs known for Hamilton
as the thing so obviously Marvel Studios
is going to want to pay Margot Robbie
and Adam Driver a little bit more
because they're the biggest names on
there that's just how it works but David
Diggs and Paul muscal are still going to
be getting a pretty big payday so it
looks like it's coming to the wire to
get this announcement out at San Diego
Comic-Con because because of Simply
contract negotiations for how much the
actors are going to get paid to play the
roles of the Fantastic Four members but
we still have over a month until San
Diego comic-con's Hall h panel that
means if they are in current
negotiations with certain actors which
it definitely seems like they are Adam
Driver Margot Robbie Paul Moscow David
Diggs they still have over a month to
come to an agreement of what is fair and
appropriate and if not Marvel Studios
definitely has other actors in mind to
play all of these different roles so
they'll move on to these other actors
and see if they can make a deal with
them however right now it definitely
seems like these four that we've talked
about are indeed The Front Runners and
who Marvel Studios wants to be the
Fantastic Four will they come out on
stage at sdcc it looks like that'll
depend on whether or not they come up
with a number that's fair for both
parties so let us know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below do
you think this should be our fantastic
forecast do you like it do you not let
us know all your thoughts down below
also don't forget to like the video
video and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month also we're now on patreon we have
a Discord server and a full website that
we post to every day we'll link all of
those down below and don't forget to
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf